je vis depuis deux ans avec mon ami
notre relation de couple est normal sauf
que quand nous faisons l'amour au moment
du spasme de la jouissance
elle enfonce mon ami enfonce très
profondément ses ongles dans mon dos
elle ne grille ça me fait très mal
j'ai beau lui dire d'arrêter de dunban
quand il fait comme ça mais elle me
répond qu'elle ne sera pas compter
qu'elle qu'elle ne fait pas exprès ça
nous ennuie beaucoup pour notre vie de
couple parce que c'est pas ça me fait
mal et moi je ne supporte pas qu est ce
que je dois faire pour le couple
j'ai l'impression que votre ami à lui
des mauvais livre où on explique que des
femmes très épanouie
drif leurs hommes dans un spasme
extatique
moi j'avais dû ça quand j'ai peut-être
un jeune fille j'ai essayé c'est une
catastrophe
alors si vous n'arrivez pas à lui
expliqué que ces mauvaises habitudes
gâche complètement votre vie de couple
il ne vous reste que trois solutions un
lui faire couper les ongles haras d'eux
portait un petit débardeur au lit on en
fait de très gentil cours très gentil et
enfin si elle vous griffe le dos changer
de position mettez vous sur le dos
croyez-moi elle aura du mal
voilà je partage l'avis d'un peintre
depuis maintenant deux ans dans
l'ensemble tout marche bien ça pourrait
marcher très bien seulement moi je
commence à perdre confiance parce que il
me refuse obstinément l'accès à son
atelier
je rêve d'être son modèle qu'il me
peigne j'ai le sentiment enfin il me dit
toujours qu'il me trouve belle et
pourtant il ne choisit pas et je ne
comprends pas beaucoup de femmes
défilent en permanence dans son atelier
et moi je suis sûr toujours depuis une
depuis qu'on se connaît en fait un peu
relégué au deuxième plan moselle vous
êtes jalouses de quitter la peinture ou
une des modèles savez les femmes
on reproche toujours à un homme de trop
s'intéresser à son métier
pourtant elle en vivent voudriez qu'ils
vous peigne mais alors vous passeriez 24
heures sur 24 avec lui vous avez ces
nuits vous avez ces réveils vous avez
fait repas et en plus il faudrait qu'ils
vous dessine surtout ses tableaux mais
c'est pas possible
en tout cas si vous formalisez du fait
qu'il vous interdis son atelier dites
vous que c'est son bureau et que les
épouses ne vont pas dans les bureaux
dites vous que ces modèles sont les
femmes qui seraient dans le bureau des
secrétaires ou des collègues
et puis jouer la confiance avec lui s'il
se passe peut-être une fois quelque
chose derrière les portes de l'atelier
si vous lui avez manifesté une confiance
parfaite il aura des remords il sera
très très gentil avec vous pour se faire
pardonner
il y a quelques mois j'ai eu un coup de
foudre pour un garçon j'ai donc quitté
mon ami pour ce garçon je pensais le
voir très localement et en fait on s'est
rendu compte qu'on sait mais encore et
donc nous avons pensé que je voudrais
vivre avec
donc ces deux garçons parce que bon j'en
ai j'en ai besoin vraiment physiquement
et moralement j'ai besoin de ses deux
garçons que j'aime énormément avec mon
ex nous en avons déjà discuté il est
d'accord mais par contre je ne sais pas
comment le présenter un nouveau jalon
chi chi le comprendra peut-être pas très
bien évidemment vous êtes dans cette
situation délicieuse d'une femme entre
deux hommes vous aimez toujours le
premier vous aimez déjà beaucoup le
deuxième
et si le premier acceptent de partager
de vous partager avec l'autre
bien sûr il vous avait entièrement et
maintenant il va récupérer une moitié de
vous mais le deuxième vous entièrement
et il va perdre une moitié de vous alors
mettez-vous à sa place d'autre part avec
vous pensez aux problèmes mobiliers et
immobiliers de cette transformation ou
habiteront nous comment partageront nous
les lits les joues pair avec l'un les
jours impairs avec l'autre et quand on
se dispute à deux c'est déjà pas mal
mais alors à 3 qu'est ce que ça doit
être